dans l'obscurité encore profond du petit
matin une lumière dans une cabane de
bois elle recèle un trésor un alambic 96
ans au compteur et son four à bois
régulièrement alimenté par samuel le
nouveau distillateur du village
j'ai fait une sorte d'apprentissage avec
mon prédécesseur d'un agriculteur en
retraite on va proposer de lui succéder
alors j'ai fait quelques journées sur
trois années à peu près quelques
journées avec lui pour apprendre la
différence
les différentes distillation et puis
voilà c'est parti
et justement voilà les clients de la
journée deux trentenaires du village
ravis de pouvoir perpétuer la tradition
ils apportent leurs propres fruits 150
litres de poires en cours de macération
à ses 500 groupes dont grands parents
nos parents n'ont fait donc on a
toujours été habitué à être là dedans ça
continue la tradition traditionnellement
puis pour le goût si ça faisait des
années qu'on n'avait pas refait et on
essaie de remédier en place ces deux-là
point de notes de notre verger
si on a quelques litres ça nous suffit
c'est ainsi plus pour le principe de de
voir ce que ça peut donner et essayer de
faire un bon produit
commence alors la transformation des
fruits en alcool dont la cuve
samuel verse les foires puis referme le
tout maintenant il faut surveiller et
attendre comme en cuisine ça fait tout
le temps donc une une chauffe lente et
progressive puis ralenti à la fin voilà
il faut savoir écouter sa cuvée rni
faits sont en son produit un produit
entouré d'un halo de mystère qu'on
imagine passé sous les manteaux pourtant
tout ici est strictement réglementée par
les services des douanes les clients
payent pour faire bouillir leur cru le
village de compte 1 voire abrite même un
syndicat de distillation quasi
centenaire on déguste on dira pas
l'heure qu'il est c'est toujours été
préservé par la commune est entretenu et
dès qu'ils aient quelque chose à faire
là c'est la commune qui pensait en
charge
on fait tout ce qu'il faut faire pour
que ça fonctionne bien et où dans la
cabane au fil des heures les effluves
évoluent elles étaient sucré et les
voilà plus capiteuse les auteurs c'est
ce qui peut mener jusqu'à vous c'est
certain les odeurs du bois et les odeurs
aussi du fruit du fruit brûlé ça sent la
confiture ça sent la tarte
voilà on vient me voir pour ça aussi fin
de la matinée cela fait maintenant plus
de trois heures que l'alambic tourne à
plein régime
quand arrive enfin le premier jus ou de
vie alors qu'est ce que ça dit c'est
très parfumée c'est très parfumée mais
il ya quand même les odeurs des terres
donc le premier jus je vais le mettre de
côté
je vais attendre un petit peu que les
jets terre disparaît je vais le mettre
de côté pour pas gâcher le coeur de
chauffe le meilleur reste à venir voilà
et là encore la patience est
définitivement mère de toutes les vertus
il faudra laisser reposer le précieux
liquide au moins trois mois avant de
pouvoir y tremper les lèvres avec
modération bien sûr